how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder and to start this off i just want
to say that this is not a video about
recasting chadwick boseman in any way
shape or form it's not about who's going
to be
the next black panther it's not about
shuri possibly
becoming the new black panther obviously
a lot of people are still mourning the
death of chadwick bozeman
and i want to be very respectful to his
family and for all of those people
who are still mourning his death but i
know a lot of people have been asking
what is going to happen we're going to
get to that of course
eventually down the road but marvel and
disney did make an
official comment of where their heads
are at right now concerning black
panther 2. and that's all we're gonna
talk about today no recasting nothing
like that
just a little update on where marvel's
heads are at and a little bit of a
backstory of
how chadwick felt up until he
unfortunately passed away
and how kevin feige found out that he
actually had cancer
so as you may have heard up until his
passing not really anybody knew
about his cancer really outside of his
family there were only a few people who
really knew that he was battling colon
cancer
and as it turns out kevin feige himself
didn't really know about it
until unfortunately he passed away the
hollywood reporter got to speak with
some people at marvel and disney and
learned a little bit more about the
heartbreaking situation
and this is what they had to say on
august 28th marvel chief creative
officer
kevin feige received an urgent email
regarding chadwick boseman with no
further information
unbeknownst to anyone at the studio the
black panther star had been battling
colon cancer privately for four plus
years and had taken a sudden turn for
the worse
by the time that feige read the message
an hour later
bozeman already had died sending
shockwaves through disney and the
tight-knit marvel cinematic universe
they go on to say that a source close to
bozeman tells the hollywood reporter
that the 43 year old actor
who had become noticeably thin in recent
months was convinced
until about a week before his death that
he was going to beat cancer and would be
able to gain the weight back for a black
panther sequel
that was scheduled to go into production
in march the actor was even set to
prepare
for the new film beginning in september
so it's just truly heartbreaking to hear
that chadwick thought that he was going
to be able to
actually film black panther 2 when he
thought that he was going to be able to
beat cancer
and it's understandable and admirable
people do it all the time and he's a
tough
guy he filmed so many different projects
while he was battling cancer and he
didn't tell anybody
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios didn't even know
until chadwick unfortunately passed away
now the article goes on to talk about
how
chadwick and black panther was a huge
part of the marvel cinematic universe
not only from what we've seen so far
but the future as well and when the
hollywood reporter asked disney
what their plans were right now what
they're focusing on and how they're
handling his death
disney sources said that the company is
processing its grief
and that its focus at this stage is to
pay tribute to bozeman and not on the
making of a black panther sequel
so rightfully so right now marvel
studios and disney is not focused on
black panther 2. they're not focused on
what do we do do we replace him do we
have shuri become the new black panther
they're not focused on that right now
if we've learned anything about chadwick
over this past week
since he passed was that he was an
amazing person and clearly meant
the world to a ton of people over at the
studio so right now they're not focused
on the loss of somebody who played a
character they're focused on the loss of
an amazing person
and it's going to be a while until
anybody talks about the recasting of
black panther or
bringing his sister shuri in to take the
role right now it's not appropriate the
appropriate thing to do is simply
let everybody mourn but i thought it
would be nice to let people know what
marvel is thinking of right now and i
thought it would be nice to let people
know that
chadwick really was a fighter he really
thought that he was going to beat cancer
and he really had every intention on
being back to film black panther 2.
but right now let's simply remember
chadwick for the awesome person that he
was and the
awesome great memories that he gave us
and marvel has been doing a great job
with the tributes that it's been putting
out so be sure to follow marvel
entertainment on youtube
on twitter on instagram they're putting
a lot of tributes to chadwick on all
those platforms
and of course if i hear anything
official about anything relating to
black panther 2
i'll let everybody know at an
appropriate time so if you want to stay
up to date on all things relating to the
mcu be sure to subscribe to my channel
and as always thank you all so much for
watching wakanda forever
you